The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, today we
are going to learn to count.
One, two, three-- In a
algorithmic sense of course,
and prove hardness of
counting style problems.
Or more generally, any problem
where the output is an integer.
Like approximation
algorithms, we
need to define a slightly
stronger version of our NP
style problem.
It's not going to be
a decision problem.
The remaining type
is a search problem.
Search problem you're
trying to find a solution.
This is just like
optimization problem,
but with no objective function.
Today all solutions
are created equal.
So we just want to know
how many there are.
So we're given an
instance, the problem.
We want to produce a solution.
Whereas in the
decision problem we
want to know whether
a solution exists.
With a search problem we
want to find a solution.
Almost the same thing.
So that would be a search
problem in general.
For an NP search problem you can
recognize what is an instance.
And you could
recognize solutions
to instances in polynomial time.
Given an instance in the
solution you can say,
yes that's a valid solution.
OK for such a search
problem of course,
is the corresponding
decision problem.
Which is, does there
exist a solution?
If you can solve this,
then you can solve that.
You could solve the
decision problem in NP
by guessing a
solution and so on.
So this is intricately related
to the notion of a certificate
for an NP problem.
The idea solutions
are certificates.
But when we say
problem is in NP,
we say there is some way
to define certificate
so that this kind of
problem can be set up.
And the goal here--
the point here
is to solidify a specific
notion of certificate.
We can't just use any
one, because we're
going to count them
the-- If you formulate
the certificates
in different ways
you'll get different counts.
But in general,
every NP problem can
be converted into an NP search
problem in at least one way.
But each notional
certificate gives you
a notion of the search problem.
OK, in some complexity context
these are called NP relations,
the way you specify
what a certificate is.
But I think this is the more
algorithmic perspective.
All right, so
given such a search
problem we turn it into
a counting problem.
So that's a search
problem, is called A.
Then counting problem will
be sharp A, not hashtag
A. Some people call it
number A. The problem is,
count the number of solutions
for a given instance.
OK so in particular, you
detect whether the number
is zero, or not zero.
So this is strictly
harder in some sense
than the decision problem,
does there exist a solution.
And we will see some problems
where the search problem is
polynomial, but the
corresponding counting problem
is actually hard.
I can't say NP
hard, there's going
to be a new notion of hardness.
So some examples.
Pretty much every problem we've
defined as a decision problem
had a search problem in mind.
So something like SAT, you need
to satisfy all of the things.
So there's no objective
function here,
but you want to know
how many different ways,
how many different variable
assignments are there that
satisfy the given formula?
Or take your favorite
pencil and paper puzzle,
we'll be looking at
Shakashaka today, again.
How many different
solutions are there?
You'd like, when
designing a puzzle,
usually you want to
know that it's unique.
So it'd be nice if you could
count the number of solutions
and show that it's one.
These problems are going to turn
out to be very hard of course.
So let's define a
notion of hardness.
Sharp P is going to be the
class of all of these counting
problems.
This is the sort of certificate.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Just for the
puzzle application,
is it going to turn out
that counting if there's
one solution versus
one-to-one solution is as hard
as just counting total numbers?
PROFESSOR: It's
not quite as hard,
but we will show that
distinguishing one
for more than one is very
hard, is NP complete actually.
That's a decision problem that
could show that's NP complete.
So normally we think
of zero versus one,
but it turns out one
versus two is not--
or one versus more than one
is about the same difficulty.
Counting is even
harder I would say.
But it's bad news all around.
There's different
notions of bad.
Cool, so this is the sort
of certificate perspective.
With NP we-- I had given you
two different definitions
of certificate perspective, and
a non-deterministic computation
perspective.
You can do the same
computational perspective here.
You could say sharp P
is the set of problems,
solved by polynomial time.
Call it a non-deterministic
counting algorithm.
We don't need Turing
machines for this definition,
although that was of course
the original definition.
So take your favorite
non-deterministic algorithm
as usual for NP, it makes
guesses at various points,
multiple branches.
With the NP algorithm the way
we'd execute it on an NP style
machine is that we would
see whether there's
any path that led to a yes.
Again, it's going to output
yes or no at the end.
In this case, what the computer
does, the sharp P style
computer, is it-- conceptually
it runs all the branches.
It counts the number of yeses
and returns that number.
So even though the algorithm is
designed to return yes or no,
when it executes it
actually outputs a number.
The original paper
says magically.
It's just as magic as an NP
machine, but a little-- even
a little more magical.
OK so you-- I mean if you're not
comfortable with that we just
use this definition, same thing.
This is all work done by Les
Valiant in the late '70s.
These notions.
So it's pretty clear,
it's pretty easy
to show all these
problems are in sharp P,
because they were-- the
corresponding decision problems
were in NP.
We convert them into
sharp P algorithms.
Now let's think about hardness
with respect to sharp P.
As usual we want
it to mean as hard
as all problems in that class.
Meaning that we can reduce all
those problems to our problem.
And the question is, by
what kind of reductions?
And here we're going to allow
very powerful reductions.
We've talked about
these reductions
but never actually been
allowed to use them.
Multicall, Cook-style
reductions.
I think in general, this
is a common approach
for FNP, which is Functions
NP style functions.
Which you can also think of
this as kind of-- the counting
version is, the
output is a value.
So you have a function instead
of just a decision question.
When the output is some thing,
some number, in this case.
You might have to manipulate
that number at the end.
And so at the very least,
you need to make a call
and do some stuff before
you return your modified
answer in your reduction.
But in fact we're going
to allow full tilt,
you could make multiple calls
to some hypothetical solution
to your problem in order to
solve all problems in sharp P.
And we'll actually use
multicall a bunch of times.
We won't always need multicall.
Often we'll be able to get
away with a much simpler kind
of reduction.
Let me tell you that kind now.
But in general we allow
arbitrary multicall.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Your not limited
in the number of multicalls?
PROFESSOR: Right.
You could do polynomial
number of multicalls.
As before, reduction
should be polynomial time.
But, so you're basically
given an algorithm.
That's usually called an Oracle
that solves your problem,
solves your problem B. And
you want to solve-- yeah,
you want to solve A by
multiple calls to B. So
what, we'll see a bunch
of examples of that.
Here's a more familiar
style of reduction.
And often, for a lot of problems
we can get away with this.
But especially a lot
of the early proofs
needed the multicall.
And as you'll see you can
do lots of cool tricks
with multicall
using number theory.
So parsimonious reduction.
This is for NP search problems.
This is going to be a lot like
an NP reduction, regular style.
So again we convert an instance
x of a, five function f,
into an instance x prime of b.
And that function should
be computable in poly time.
So far just like
an NP reduction.
And usually we would say,
for a search problem,
we would say there
exists a solution
for x, if and only if, there
exists a solution for x prime.
That would be the direct analog
of an NP style reduction.
But we're going to ask
for a stronger condition.
Which is that the number
of solutions to problem
A to instance x, equals the
number of solutions of type B
to instance x prime.
OK so in particular, this
one's going to equal to one,
this one will be greater than
equal to one, and vice versa.
So this is stronger
than an NP style
reduction for the
corresponding decision problem.
Yeah, so I even wrote that down.
This implies that the decision
problems have the same answer.
So in particular, this implies
that we have an NP reduction.
So in particular if A,
the decision version of A
is NP hard, then the decision
version of B is NP hard.
But more interesting is
that, if A is sharp P hard,
then B is sharp P hard.
But also this holds for NP.
For the decision versions
of A and B. Sorry,
sharp A and sharp B. OK this
is a subtle distinction.
For sharp P hardness we're
talking about the counting
problems, and we're
talking about making calls
to other counting solutions.
Then doing things with those
numbers and who knows what,
making many calls.
With parsimonious
reduction we're
thinking about the
non-counting version.
Just the search problem.
And so we're not worried about
counting solutions directly,
I mean it-- what's nice
about parsimonious reductions
is they look just
like NP reductions
for the regular old problems.
We just need this
extra property,
parsimony that the number
of solutions to the unit
is preserved through
the transformation.
And a lot of the proofs
that we've covered follow--
have this property and
will be good for us.
If we can get our
source problems hard,
then we'll get a lot of
target problems hard as well.
Well let me tell you about one
more version which I made up.
C-monious reductions.
This is my attempt
at understanding
the entomology of parsimonious.
Which is something like little
money, being very thrifty.
So this is having a
little bit more money.
You have C dollars.
But you have to be very
consistent about it.
I should probably add
some word that means
uniform in the middle there.
But I want the number of
solutions of x prime to equal
c times the number
of solutions to x.
C a fixed constant.
And it has to be the
same for every x.
This would be just as good
from a sharp P perspective.
Because if I could solve
B and I wanted to solve A,
I would convert A to B, run
the thing, then divide by C.
There will never be a remainder
and then I have my answer to A.
As long as C's not zero.
C should be an integer here.
We will see a bunch of
C-monious reductions.
I guess, yeah it doesn't have
to be totally independent of x.
It can depend on things like n.
Something that we can
compute easily I guess.
Shouldn't be too dependent on x.
All right, let's do-- let's
look at some examples.
So, going to make a list here
of sharp P complete problems.
And we'll start with versions
of SAT because we like SAT.
So I'm just going to tell
you that sharp 3SAT is hard.
First sharp SAT is hard, and
the usual proof of SAT hardness
shows sharp P completeness
for sharp SAT.
And if you're careful about
the conversion from SAT to 3CNF
you can get sharp
three satisfied.
It's not terribly
interesting and tedious.
So I will skip that one.
So what about Planar 3SAT?
I stared at this diagram
many times for a while.
This is lecture seven for
replacing a crossing in a 3SAT
thing with this picture.
And all of this argument and
this table in particular,
was concluding
that the variables
are forced in this scenario.
If you know what
A and B are-- so
once you choose
what A and B are,
these two have to
be copies of A and B
and then it ended up
that A-- We proved
that A1 equaled A2
and B1 equaled B2,
and then these
variables were all
determined by these formula.
And so once you know A and
B all the variable settings
are forced.
Which means you preserve
the number of solutions.
So planar sharp 3SAT
is sharp P complete.
I'd like to pretend that there's
some debate within the sharp P
community about whether the
sharp P are here or here.
I kind of prefer it here,
but I've seen it over here,
so you know.
I don't think I've even
seen that mentioned but I'm
sure it's out there somewhere.
So let's flip through our
other planar hardness proofs.
This is planar monotone
rectilinear 3SAT.
Mainly the monotone aspect.
We wanted there to
be all the variables
to be positive or
negative in every clause.
And so we had this trick
for forcing this thing
to be not equal to this thing.
Basically copying the variable
with a flip in its truths.
But again everything
here is forced.
The variables we
make are guaranteed
to be copies or indications
of other variables.
So we preserve
number of solutions.
So this is hard too.
OK, what else?
I think we can-- I
just made this up
--but we can add the
dash three as usual
by replacing each variable
with little cycle.
What about planar 1-in-3 SAT?
So we had, we actually had
two ways to prove this.
This is one of the
reductions and we
check that this set
of SAT clauses, these
are the SAT clauses implemented
this 1-in-3 SAT clause.
And I stared at this for a while
and its kind of hard to tell.
So I just wrote a program
to enumerate all cases
and found there's
exactly one case where
this is not parsimonious.
And that's when this is
false and these two are true.
And because of these
negations you can either
solve the internal
things like this,
or you could flip all
of the internal nodes
and that will also be satisfied.
Now this is bad news, because
all the other cases there
is a unique solution over here.
But in this case there
are exactly two solutions.
If it was two everywhere
we'd be happy,
that would be twomonious.
If it was one everywhere
we'd be happier, happy
that would be parsimonious.
But because it's a
mixture of one and two
we have approximately
preserved the counts
with a factor of two.
But that's not good
enough for sharp P,
we need exact preservation.
So this is no good.
Luckily we had another
proof which was actually
a stronger result, Planar
Positive Rectilinear 1-in-3SAT.
This was a version
with no negation,
and this one does work.
There's first of all
this, the not equal gadget
and the equal gadget.
I don't want to go through them,
but again A forced to be zero,
C was forced to be one,
which forces B and D to be
zero in this picture.
So all is good.
And again parsimonious there.
And then this one was too
complicated to think about,
so I again wrote a
program to check-- try
all the cases and
every choice of XYZ
over here that's satisfied,
this is a reduction from 3SAT.
So if at least one
of these is true,
there will be exactly
one solution over here.
And just as before after--
if zero of them are true,
then they'll be
no solution here.
That we already knew.
So good news.
I should check whether that's
mentioned in their paper
but it proves planar positive
rectilinear 1-in-3SAT
is sharp P complete.
Sharp go here, here.
OK, so lots of fun results.
We get a lot of results
just from-- by looking
at old proofs.
Now they're not
all going to work,
but I have one more
example that does work.
Shakashaka, remember the puzzle?
It's a Nikoli puzzle.
Every square,
every white squared
can be filled in with a black
thing, but adjacent to it too,
there should be
exactly two of those.
And you want all of the
resulting white regions
to be rectangles
possibly rotated.
And we had this reduction
from planar 3SAT,
and this basically,
this type of wire.
And there's exactly two
ways to solve a wire.
One for true, one for false.
So once you know
what the variable is,
you're forced what
to do, there is also
a parity-shifting gadget
and splits and turns.
But again, exactly two
ways to solve everything.
So parsimonious, and then
the clause everything
was basically
forced just-- you're
forced whether to have
these square diamonds.
And you just
eliminated the one case
where the clause
is not satisfied.
So there's really no flexibility
here, one way to solve it.
And so it's a
parsimonious reduction
and indeed in the
paper we mentioned
this implies sharp P
completeness of counting
Shakashaka solutions.
Cool.
Here's an example
that doesn't work.
A little different,
Hamiltonicity or I
guess I want to count the
number of Hamiltonian cycles.
The natural counting
version of Hamiltonicity.
So we had two proofs for
this, neither of them
work in a sharp P sense.
This one, remember
the idea was that you
would traverse back and
forth one way or the other
to get all of these nodes.
That was a variable,
that's fine.
There're exactly
two ways to do that.
But then the clause,
the clause had
to be satisfied by at least
one of the three variables.
And if it's satisfied
for example,
by all three variables,
then it could
be this node is
picked up like this,
or the node could be
picked up this way,
picked up this way.
So there are three
different solutions even
for one fixed
variable assignment.
So that's bad, we're
not allowed to do that.
It'd be fine if every one was
three, but some will be one,
some will be two,
some will be three.
That's going to be some
weird product of those
over the clauses.
So that doesn't work.
We had this other proof.
This was a notation
for this gadget which
forced either this directed
edge or this directed edge
to be used, but not both.
It's and x or.
So that's, remember
what these things meant
and that we have the
variable true or false.
And then we connected
them to the clauses,
then separately we
had a crossover.
But the trouble
is in the clauses,
because again, the idea was that
the variable chose this guy,
this one was forbidden.
That's actually the
good case I think.
If the variable chose
this, chose this one,
then this one must be included.
That's bad news, if you
followed this, and then this,
and then this, then you cut
off this part of the graph
and you don't get one
Hamiltonian cycle.
You want at least one variable
to allow you to go left here
and then you can go and grab
all this stuff and come back.
But again if multiple
variables satisfy this thing,
any one of them could
grab the left rectangle.
And so they get multiple
solutions, not parsimonious.
But parts of this
proof are useful
and they are used to make
a parsimonious proof.
So the part that was useful is
this x or gadget, and the way
to implement crossovers.
So just remember that
you can build x ors,
and that you can cross them
over using a bunch of x ors.
So only x or connections,
these notations,
can be crossed in this view.
We're going to
build more gadgets
and this is a proof
by Sato in 2002.
It was a bachelor's
thesis actually in Japan.
And so here you see
redrawn the x or gadget.
Here it's going to be
for undirected graph,
same structure works.
And this is do the
crossover using x or.
So he's denoting x or's as this
big X connected to two things.
Now given that we can
build an or gadget, which
says that either we use this
edge or we use this edge,
or both.
Here we're not using an x
or, but this is the graph.
And the key is this has
to be done uniquely.
That's in particular
the point of these dots.
This looks asymmetric,
it's kind of weird.
For example, if they're both
in, then this guy can do this,
and this guy can do that.
But it's not symmetric.
You couldn't flip-- this guy
can't grab these points, that
would be a second solution
which would be bad,
but we missed these points.
So this guy has to stay
down here if he's in at all.
And then this guy's
the only one who
can grab those extra points.
Or if just the top guy's
in then you do this.
And if just the bottom guy's
in I think it's symmetric.
That is symmetric,
and it's unique.
Good.
If there's an implication-- so
this says if this edge is in,
then that edge must be
in the Hamiltonian cycle
and this is
essentially by copying.
And we just have to
grab an extra edge
and add this little extra
thing just for copying value.
So if this one is in, then
this edge must not be used,
which means this edge if
it's used must go straight.
In particular, this is not used.
And we have an or that
means that this one must
be forced by a property of or.
On the other hand, if this is
not set, this one must be used.
So I guess this must be
an edge that was already
going to be used for something.
So that edge is just going
to get diverted down here,
and then the or doesn't
constrain us at all.
Because zero or one, this one
is one so the or is happy.
So that's an implication.
It's going to be a little more
subtle how we combine these.
This is the tricky gadget.
I sort of understand
it, but it has
a lot of details to
check, especially
on the uniqueness front.
But this is a three-way
or which we're
using for clause, SAT
clause, 3SAT clause.
We want at least one
of these three edges
to be in the Hamiltonian cycle.
And so here we use x ors, ors,
implications, and more x ors.
I'll show you the
intended solution,
assuming I can remember it.
So let's say for example, this
edge is in the Hamiltonian
cycle.
Then we're going to do
something like go over here,
come back around like this.
And then
AUDIENCE: Did you just
violate the x or already?
PROFESSOR: This x or?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: No, I went here.
AUDIENCE: And then you went up.
PROFESSOR: Oh, then
I went up, good.
So actually I have to
do this and around.
Yes, so all these constraints
are thrown in, basically
to force it to be unique.
Without them you could--
still it would still work,
but it wouldn't be parsimonious.
OK, let's see, this--
AUDIENCE: In the middle.
PROFESSOR: --doesn't
constrain me.
This one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Good, go up there.
So I did exactly one of those
and then I need to grab these.
OK, so that's one picture.
I think it's not
totally symmetric.
Again, so you have to
check all three of them.
And you have to check for
example, It's not so hard.
Like if this guy was also in,
I could have just gone here
and this guy would
pick up those nodes.
So as long as, in general, as
long as at least one of them
is on you're OK.
And furthermore,
if they're all on,
there's still a unique
way to solve it.
And I'm not going
to go through that.
But it's thanks to all
of these constraints
they're cutting out
multiple solutions.
OK, so now we just had
to put these together,
this is pretty easy.
It's pretty much
like the old proof.
Again, we have-- we
represent variables
by having these double edges
in a Hamiltonian cycle.
You're going to choose
one or the other.
And then we have this exclusive
or, forcing y and y bar
to choose opposite choices.
And then there are these
exclusive words to say,
if you chose that one,
then you can't choose it
for this clause.
And then the clauses
are just represented
by those three-way ors.
So this overall
structure is the same.
The crossovers
are done as before
and it's really these
gadgets that have changed.
And they're complicated,
but it's parsimonious.
So with a little more work.
We get the number of
Hamiltonian cycles
in planar max degree three
graphs is sharp P complete.
So that's nice.
And from that, we
get Slitherlink.
So this is-- I've sort of been
hiding these facts from you.
When we originally
covered these proofs,
these papers actually talk
about-- This one doesn't quite
talk about sharp P, but it
is also sharp P complete.
Counting the number of
solutions to Slitherlink
is sharp P complete.
This was the puzzle.
Again you have that number of
adjacent edges-- each number.
And the proof was a
reduction from planar max
degree three Hamiltonian cycle.
And at the time I
said, oh you could just
assume it's a grid graph.
And then you just need
the required gadget,
which is the b part.
Just need this gadget.
This was a gadget because
it had these ones.
It meant it had to be
traversed like a regular vertex
in Hamiltonian cycle
and it turns out
there was a way to traverse
it straight or with returns.
And then we could block
off edges wherever there
wasn't supposed to be an edge.
And so if you're reducing from
Hamiltonicity and grid graphs
that was the whole
proof and we were happy.
Now we don't know whether
Hamiltonicity and grid
graphs is sharp P complete.
To prove that we
would need to be
able to put bipartite
in here, and I
don't know of a proof of that.
Good open problem.
So this was the reason that they
have this other gadget, which
was to make Hamiltonian-- to
make these white vertices that
don't have to be traversed.
They're just implementing
an edge basically.
So just the black vertices
have to be traversed.
We needed that for drawing
things on the grid.
But if you just don't put in
the ones and add in these zeros
again you can traverse
it or not all.
And this one, as
you can read here,
says this would be
bad to have happen.
In fact you can rule
it out, it will never
happen in the
situations we want.
Because the white vertices
only have two neighbors
that are traversable.
Cool, and then furthermore, all
of these solutions are unique.
There is exactly one
way to go straight.
There's exactly one way to
turn right, exactly one way
to turn left.
That's the subtle thing that
was not revealed before.
But if you stare at it long
enough you will be convinced.
So this is a
parsimonious reduction
from planar max degree
three Hamiltonian
cycle to Slitherlink.
So counting solutions
in Slitherlink is hard.
That was the fully
worked out example.
Any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So are there
examples of problems in P
who's counting versions
are sharp P complete?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And that will be the next topic.
Well it's going to be a
little while til we get there.
But I'm going to proof
things and then we
will get to an answer,
but the answer is yes.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So, for if
we wanted-- if we're
like thinking about
a problem that we're
trying to prove something
P-hard and we start thinking
maybe stop, we would just show
it's in P by finding algorithm.
Is there a nice way to show
that our problem is not P hard?
PROFESSOR: Well you usually
would say that sharp,
that problem is NP.
You find a polynomial
counting algorithm.
And they're lot's of examples of
polynomial counting algorithms
especially on like trees.
Typical thing is
your dynamic program.
So like maybe you want
to know-- let's say
you have a rooted binary
tree and for each node
you could flip it
this way or not.
How many different ways
are there to do that?
And maybe have some
constraints on how that's done.
Then you just try it
flipped, and try it not.
You do dynamic
programming and then
you multiply the two
solution sizes together,
and you get the
overall solution size.
So you basically
do combinatorics
and if there's
independent choices you
multiply, if they're
opposing choices you add,
that kind of thing.
And from that you get polynomial
time counting algorithms.
In tree-like things that
often works inbound treewidth.
AUDIENCE: Do you know that NP
hard problems who's counting
problems are not sharp P hard?
I guess this technique
wouldn't work.
PROFESSOR: I would say
generally most problems
that are hard to decide
are hard to count.
And where NP hard
implies sharp P hard.
I don't think there's a
hard theorem in that there's
nothing that really says--
meta-theorem that says that,
but that's the feeling.
It'd be nice, then
we wouldn't have
to do all the parsimonious work.
All right so it's time for a
little bit of linear algebra.
Let me remind you, I
guess linear algebra's not
a pre-req for this class,
but probably you've
seen the determinant
of a matrix and use,
if it's zero then it's
non-invertible blah, blah,
blah.
Let me remind you
of a definition.
And we rarely use
matrix notation.
So let me remind you
of the usual one.
N by n, square matrix.
This is a polynomial
time problem.
It is-- but I'm going to define
it in an exponential way.
But you probably know a
polynomial time algorithm.
This is not an algorithms class
so you don't need to know it.
But it's based on Gaussian
elimination, the usual one.
So you look at all
permutation matrices,
all n by n permutation
matrices which
you can think of as a
permutation pi on the numbers 1
through n.
And you look at i
comma pi event, that
defines the permutation matrix.
You take the product
of the matrix
values-- if you superimpose
the permutation matrix on that,
on the given matrix A.
You take that product
you possibly negate it
if the sign of your
permutation was negative,
if it does an even number-- an
odd number of transpositions
then this will be negative.
Otherwise, it'd be positive
and you add those up.
So of course, an exponential
number permutations
you wouldn't want to do this as
an algorithm but turns out it
can be done in polynomial time.
The reason for
talking about this
is by analogy I want the
notion of permanent, of an n
by n matrix.
The same thing, but
with this removed.
The determinant of A is the
sum over all permutations pi,
of the product from i equals
one to n of ai, pi of i.
Now this may not look
like a counting problem.
It turns out it is a
counting problem, sort of,
a weighted counting problem.
We will get back to counting
problems in a moment.
This Is related to the number
of perfect matchings in a graph.
But at this point
it's just-- it's
a quantity we want to compute.
This is a function of a matrix.
And computing this function
is sharp P complete.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could it just be
sine minus 1 2e sine of pi?
PROFESSOR: I don't
know, it depends.
If you call the number of
transpositions mod two so then
it's zero one.
You know what I mean.
All right.
So the claim is, permanent
is sharp P complete.
We're going to prove this.
This was the original problem
proved sharp P complete.
Well other than
sharp 3SAT I guess.
Same paper.
Great so let me give
you a little intuition
of what the permanent is.
We'd like a definition
that's not so algebraic.
At least I would like one more
graph-theoretic would be nice.
So here's what
we're going to do.
We're going to convert A, our
matrix, into a weighted graph.
And then let me go
to the other board.
How do we convert
into a weighted graph,
weighted directed graph?
Well the weight from,
vertex I to vertex J is AIJ.
The obvious transformation
if it's zero then
there's not going to be an edge,
although it doesn't matter.
You could leave the edge
in with weight zero,
it will be the same.
Because what we're
interested in, in the claim
is the permanent of the
matrix equals the sum,
of the product of edge
weights, over all cycle covers
of the graph.
OK, this is really just the same
thing, but a little bit easier
to think about.
So a cycle cover it's kind
of like a Hamiltonian cycle
but there could be
multiple cycles.
So at every vertex you
should enter and leave.
And so you have sort of in
degree one and out degree one.
So you end up decomposing the
graph into vertex destroyed
cycles which hit every vertex.
That's a cycle cover.
Important note here, we do
have loops in the graph.
We can't have loops
if aii is not zero.
Then you have a loop.
So the idea is to look
at every cycle cover
and just take the product
of the edge weights
that are edges in
the cycles and then
add that up overall
cycle covers.
So it's the same thing
if you stare at it
long enough because
you're going from I.
I mean this is
basically the cycle
decomposition of the permutation
if you know permutation theory.
So if you don't,
don't worry this is
your definition of permanent.
So we're going to prove this
problem, is sharp P complete?
And we're going to prove
it by a C-monious reduction
from sharp 3SAT.
AUDIENCE: You said this is just
the original thing introducing
that?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Did they not call it--
you made up the term C-monious.
What did they call it?
PROFESSOR: I think they
just called it a reduction.
I think pretty sure, they
just called it reduction.
And for them-- and they
said at the beginning,
--reduction means
multicall reduction.
So they're thinking about that.
But it turns out to be
a C-monious reduction.
C will not be
literally constant,
but it will be a function
of the problem sets.
And this is the reduction.
So as usual, we have a clause
gadget, and a variable gadget,
and then there's
this shaded thing
which is this matrix, which
you can think of as a graph.
But in this case will
be easier to just think
of as a black box matrix.
OK all of the edges in these
pictures have weight one.
And then these
edges are special,
and here you have some
loops in the center.
No one else has a loop.
So the high-level
idea is if you're
thinking of a cycle
cover in a vertex
because you--
sorry, in a variable
because you've got a vertex
here and a vertex here you
have to cover them somehow.
And the intent is that you
either cover this one this way,
or you cover this
one that way, those
would be the true and the false.
And then from the
clouds perspective
we need to understand, so then
these things are connected.
This thing would go
here and this thing
would go here, and
generally connect variables
to clauses in the obvious way.
And in general, for every
occurrence of the positive form
and the negative form, sorry
positive or negative form
you'll have one of these blobs
that connects to the clause.
So overall architecture
should be clear.
What does this gadget do?
It has some nifty properties
let me write them down.
So this matrix is
called x in the paper.
So first of all, permanent
of x equals zero.
I'm just going to
state these, I mean
you could check them by
doing the computation.
So we're interested in cycle
covers whose products are not
zero.
Otherwise they don't
contribute to the sum.
So I could also add in non-zero.
Meaning the product is non-zero.
OK so if we had a cycle cover
that just-- where the cycle
cover just locally solved this
thing by traversing these four
vertices all by themselves.
Then that cycle would
have permanent zero.
And then the permanent
of the whole cycle
covers the product
of those things.
And so the overall
thing would be zero.
So if you look at
a nonzero cycle
cover you can't just
leave these isolated,
you have to visit them.
You have to enter
them and leave them.
Now the question is, where
could you enter and leave them?
This is maybe not totally
clear from the drawing
but, the intent is that
the first vertex in-- which
corresponds to row one, column
one here, is the left side.
And the column four, row
four is the right side.
I claim that you have
to enter at one of those
and leave at the other.
Why is that true?
For a couple reasons.
One is that the permanent
of x with row and column
one removed is zero,
and so is the permanent
of x with row and
column four removed.
OK vertex one and four
out of this x matrix
are the only places you
could enter and leave.
But it's possible you enter
and then immediately leave.
So you just touch
the thing and leave.
That would correspond to
leaving behind a three
by three sub-matrix.
Either by deleting
this row and column,
or by deleting this row and
column if you just visit
this vertex and leave.
Those also have permanent zero.
So if you're looking at
a nonzero cycle cover
you can't do that.
So together those mean
that you enter one of them
and leave at the other.
And furthermore, if you look
at the permanent of x with rows
and columns one and four
removed, both removed,
that's also zero.
So the permanent of
this sub-matrix is zero
and therefore you can't
just enter here, jump here,
and leave.
Which means finally you have
to traverse all four vertices.
You enter at one of them,
traverse everything,
and leave at the other.
So basically this
is a forced edge.
If you touch here you have to
then traverse and leave there,
in any cycle cover.
So we're used to seeing forced
edges in Hamiltonian cycle.
This is sort of a
stronger form of it.
That's cool now one catch.
So if you do that, if you
enter let's say vertex one
and leave at vertex four, you
will end up-- your contribution
to the cycle will end up
being the permanent of x
minus row one and column four.
Or symmetrically
with four and one.
You'd like this to be
one, but it's four.
So there are four ways to
traverse the forced edge.
But because it's
always four, or zero,
and then it doesn't
contribute at all.
It's always going to be four
so this will be a nice uniform
blow up in our
number of solutions.
C is not going to
be four, but it's
going to be four to some power.
It's going to be
four to the power,
the number of those gadgets.
So because you can
predict that, I
mean in the reduction you know
exactly how many there it's not
depend on the solution,
it's only dependent on how
you built this thing.
So at the end, we're
going to divide by four
to the power-- it's I think five
times the number of clauses.
So C is going to be four to
the power of five times number
of clauses because
there are five
of these gadgets per clause.
So at the end we'll just
divide by that and be done.
AUDIENCE: Would it be 10
times because you got it
on the variable side too?
PROFESSOR: Yes 10
times, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Eight-- two
of those don't actually
connect to variables.
PROFESSOR: Two of
them do not connect
to variables, yeah eight.
Eight times the
number of clauses.
All right so now it's
just a matter of-- now
that you understand
what this is now
you could sort of see how
information is communicated.
Because if the variable they
choose is the true setting
it must visit these edges.
And once it touches here
it has to leave here
and this is a edge
going the wrong way.
So you can't try to traverse--
from here you cannot touch
the clauses down below.
Once you touch here
to you have to go here
and then you must
leave here and so on.
But you leave this
one behind and it
must be traversed by the
clause and vice versa.
If I choose this one then these
must be visited by the clauses.
So from the clause
perspective as he
said there are five of these
gadgets, but only three of them
are connected.
So these guys are forced, and
there's a bunch of edges here
and it's a case analysis.
So it'd be the short version.
Let's just do a
couple of examples.
If none of these
have been traversed
by the variable then
the-- pretty much
you have to go straight through.
But then you're in trouble.
Because there's no pointer
back to the beginning.
You can only go back this far.
So if none of-- if you have
to traverse all these things
it's not possible
with the cycle cover.
But if any one of them
has been traversed.
So for example, if this
one has been traversed then
we'll jump over it,
visit these guys,
jump back here, visit this
guy, and jump back there.
And if you check that's the
only way to do it, it's unique.
And similarly any one of
them has been covered,
or if all three of them have
been covered, or if two of them
have been covered
in all cases this
is a unique way from
the clause perspective
to connect all the things.
Now in reality,
there's four ways
to traverse each
of these things.
So the whole thing
grows by this product
but it doesn't matter
which cycle they appear in.
We'll always scale the number
of solutions by factor of four.
So it's nice uniform
scaling C-monious.
And that's permanent.
Pretty cool.
Pretty cool proof.
Now one not so nice
thing about this proof
is it involves numbers negative
one, zero, one, two, and three.
For reasons we will
see in a moment
it'd be really to
just use zero and one.
And it turns out
that's possible,
but it's kind of annoying.
It's nifty though.
I think this will demonstrate
a bunch of fun number theory
things you could do.
So next goal is
zero one permanent.
Now the matrix is
just zero's and one's.
This is sharp P complete.
I'll tell you the reason that
is particularly interesting.
As it gets rid of
the weights it makes
it more clearly-- makes it more
clearly a counting problem.
So first of all is the
number of cycle covers
in the corresponding graph.
No more weights it's
just-- if it's a zero
there's not an edge.
Since you can't traverse
there if it's a one
you can traverse there
and then every cycle cover
will have product one.
So it's just counting them.
But it also happens to be the
number of perfect matchings
in a bipartite graph.
Which bipartite graph?
The bipartite graph where
one side of the bi-partition
is the rows and the other side
is the columns of the matrix.
And you have an edge I j.
If and only if a i sorry
j is not a good not
the best terminology
for I-- where I here's
is a vertex of v one and
j is a vertex of v two.
Whenever I j equals 1, if
it's zero there's no edge.
It's a little confusing because
the matrix is not symmetric
so you might say well, how does
this make an undirected graph?
Because you could have and edge
from i to j, but not to j to I.
That's OK because I is
interpreted in the left space
and j is interpreted
in the right space.
So the asymmetric
case would be the case
that there's an edge here to
here, but not an edge from here
to here.
That's perfectly OK.
This is one, two, three,
for a three by three matrix
we get a six vertex
graph, not three vertex.
That's what allows you to be
asymmetric on a loop, what
we were normally thinking
is a loop just means
a horizontal edge.
OK so it turns out if you
look at this graph, which
is a different graph from
what we started with,
the number of perfect
matchings in that graph
is equal to the number of cycle
covers in the other graph,
in the directed graph.
So this one's undirected
and bipartite.
This one was directed
and not bipartite.
And the rough intuition
is that we're just
kind of pulling
the vertices apart
into two versions, the left
version and the right version.
If you imagine there being
a connection from one
right to one left and similarly
from two right to two left
directed.
And three right to three left,
hey it looks like cycles again.
You went here, then you went
around, then you went here,
then you went there.
That was a cycle and
similarly this is a cycle.
So they're the same thing.
This is cool because
perfect matchings
are interesting in
particular perfect matchings
are easy to find
in polynomial time.
But counting them
as Sharp P complete.
Getting back to that question.
So that's why we care about zero
one permanence or one reason
to care about it.
Let's prove that it's hard.
And here we'll use a number
theory, pretty basic number
theory.
So first claim is
that computing the
permanent of a matrix, general
matrix nonzero one modulo
given integer r is hard.
r has to be an input
for this problem.
It's not like computing at
Mod three necessarily as hard,
but computing at modular
anything is hard.
And here we're going to finally
use some multi-color reduction
power.
So the idea is, suppose you
could solve this problem then
I claim I can solve permanent.
Anyone know how?
AUDIENCE: Chinese
remainder theorem?
PROFESSOR: Chinese
remainder theorem
OK if you don't know the
Chinese remainder theorem
but you should know it.
It's good.
So the idea is
we're going to set r
to be all primes up to how big?
Or we can stop when the
product of all the primes
that we've considered is bigger
than the potential permanent.
And the permanent is at
most m to the n times
n factorial, where
m is the largest
absolute value in the matrix.
That's one upper bound,
doesn't really matter.
But the point is,
it is computable
and if you take the
logarithm it's not so big.
All these numbers
are at least two.
All primes are at least two.
So the number of primes
we'll have to consider
is at most log base 2 of that.
So this means the
number of primes,
so that's log of m to
the n times n factorial,
and this is roughly--
I'll put a total here.
This is like m
log n that's exact
plus n log n that's approximate
but it's minus order n
so it won't hurt us.
So that's good,
that's a polynomial.
Log m is a reasonable thing,
m was given us as a number
so log n is part of this input.
So as our input and n is
obviously good as the dimension
of the matrix.
So this is a polynomial
number of calls.
We're going to compute
the permanent mod
r for all these things and
our Chinese remainder theorem
tells you if you
know a number which
is the permanent module
all primes whose products--
Well if you know a number of
modulo a bunch of primes then
you can figure out the number of
modulo, the product of primes.
And if we set the product to
be bigger than the number could
be, then we know [? any ?]
modulo that is actually
knowing the number itself.
So then we can
reconstruct the permanent.
So here we're really
using multicall.
I think that's the
first time I've
used Chinese remainder theorem
in a class that I've taught.
Good stuff.
AUDIENCE: Do you know why it's
called the Chinese remainder
theorem?
PROFESSOR: I assume
it was proved
by a Chinese mathematician
but I-- anyone know?
AUDIENCE: Sun Tzu.
PROFESSOR: Sun Tzu.
OK I've heard of him.
AUDIENCE: Not the guy
who did Art of War.
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
I don't know him then.
Another Sun Tzu.
Cool, yeah so permanent
mod r is hard.
Next claim is that the zero
one permanent mod r is hard.
The whole reason
we're going to mod
r-- I mean it's interesting
to know that computing
permanent mod r is just
as hard as permanent
but it's kind of standard thing.
The reason I wanted
to go to mod r
was to get rid of
these negative numbers.
Negative numbers are annoying.
Once I go to mod any r
negative numbers flip around
and I can figure everything
is positive or non-negative.
Now I can go back
to gadget land.
So suppose I have an
edge of weight five,
this will work for any
number greater than one.
If It's one I don't touch it.
If it's greater than one I'm
going to make this thing.
And the claim is there
are exactly five ways
to use this edge.
Either you don't use it
and you don't use it.
But if you do use it,
exactly five ways to use it.
If you make this traversal,
there are five ways to do it.
Remember this has
to be a cycle cover
so we have to visit everything.
If you come up here, can't go
that way gotta go straight.
Can't go that way,
got to go straight.
Hmm, OK.
So in fact, the rest
of this cycle cover
must be entirely
within this picture.
And so for example, you
could say that's a cycle
and then that's a
cycle, these are loops.
And then that's a
cycle and then that's
a cycle and then that's a
cycle and then that's a cycle.
And whoops I'm left
with one vertex.
So in fact I have to choose
exactly one of the loops,
put that in and the
rest can be covered.
For example, if I choose this
guy then this will be a cycle,
this'll be a cycle,
this will be a cycle.
Perfect parity this will be
a cycle, is will be a cycle,
and this will be a cycle.
Can't choose two loops.
If I chose like
these two groups then
this guy would be isolated.
So you have to choose
exactly one loop
and there are
exactly five of them.
In general you make-- there'd be
k of them if you want weight k,
and you can simulate.
If you don't use this edge then
there's actually only one way
to do it.
You have to go all the
way around like this.
So that's cool.
If you don't use the edge,
didn't mess with anything.
If you use the edge you
get a weight of five.
Multiplicative, because
this is independent of all
the other such choices.
So you can simulate a
high-weight edge, module r.
In general you can simulate
a non-negative weight edge
like this.
Just these are all weight one
obviously and absent edges
are zero.
So we can convert
in the module r
setting there are no
negative numbers essentially.
So we can just do that
simulation, everything
will work mod r.
So use gadget.
Now finally we can prove
zero one permanent is hard.
Why?
Because if we could compute
the zero one permanent
we can compute at mod r.
Just compute the permanent,
take the answer mod r and you
solve zero one permanent mod r.
So this is what I might
call a one-call reduction.
It's not our usual notion
of one-call reduction
because we're doing
stuff at the end.
But I'm going to use
one-call in this setting.
Just call it-- in fact we don't
even have to change the input.
Then we get the output
when we computed mod r.
Question.
AUDIENCE: So in
that the weight you
can have really high weight.
But then your
[INAUDIBLE] nodes so then
when you use that wouldn't n?
PROFESSOR: Oh I see.
If the weights were
exponentially large
this would be bad news.
But they're not
exponentially large
because we know they're
all at most three.
They're between
negative one and three.
Oh but negative
one-- Yes, OK good
I need the prime number theorem.
Thank you.
So we have numbers
negative one then
we're mapping them
modulo some prime.
Now negative one is actually
the prime minus one.
So indeed, we do get weights
that are as large as r.
So this is-- r here we're
assuming is encoded in unary.
It turns out we can afford
to encode the primes in unary
because the number
of primes that we use
is this polynomial thing,
a weakly polynomial thing.
And by the prime number theorem,
the prime with that index
is roughly that big.
It's the log factor larger.
So the primes are going
to-- the actual value
of the prime is going to
be something like n log
m, times log base e, and log m.
By the prime number theorem and
that's again weakly polynomial.
And so we can assume
ours encoded in unary.
Wow, we get to use the prime
number theorem that's fun.
AUDIENCE: Is that the first time
you had to use prime numbers?
PROFESSOR: Probably.
Pretty sure I've used prime
number theorem if and only
if I've used Chinese
remainder theorem.
They go hand in hand.
Clear?
So this was kind
of roundabout way,
but we ended up getting rid
of the negative numbers.
Luckily it still worked.
And now it's zero
one permanence hard,
therefore counting the number
of perfect matchings in a given
bipartite graph isn't
going to be hard.
These problems were equivalent,
like they're identical.
So you could-- this was
a reduction in one way
but that's equally
reducible both ways.
So you can reduce this
one, reduce this one
to perfect matchings
or vice versa.
All right.
Here's some more fun
things we can do.
Guess I can add to my list here.
But in particular we
have zero one permanent.
So there are other ways you
might be interested in counting
matchings.
So, so far we know it's hard
to count perfect matchings.
So in a balanced bipartite graph
we had n vertices on the left,
and n vertices on the right.
We're going to use that.
Then the hope is that
there's matching a size n.
But in general, you could
just count maybe those
don't exist at all.
Maybe we just want to
count maximal matchings.
These are not maximum matchings.
Maximal, meaning you can't
add any more edges to them.
They're locally maximum.
So that's going to
be a bigger number,
it's going to be always
bigger than zero.
Because the empty
matching, well you
could start with
the empty matching
and add things you'll get at
least one maximal matching.
But this is also
sharp P complete,
and you can prove
it using some tricks
from bipartite perfect
matching, counting.
Don't have a ton
of time so I'll go
through this relatively quick.
We're going to take each vertex
and convert it, basically
make n copies of it.
And when we have an edge
that's going to turn
into a biclique between them.
Why did I address
such a big one?
This was supposed to be n and n.
OK so just blow up every edge.
My intent is to make matchings
become more plentiful.
So in general, if I used to
have a matching of size i,
I end up converting it into n
factorial to the i-th power,
distinct matchings
of size n times i.
OK because if I
use an edge here,
now I get to put in a
arbitrary perfect matching
in this biclique and
they're n factorial of them.
Cool, why did I do that?
Because now I
suppose that I knew
how to count the number
of maximum actions.
So they're going to be
matchings of various sizes.
From that I want to extract the
number of perfect matchings.
Sounds impossible, but
when you make things giant
like this they kind of-- all
the matchings kind of separate.
It's like biology or something.
Chemistry.
So let's see, it
shows how much I know.
Number of maximal
matchings is going
to be sum i equals
zero to n over 2.
That's the possible
sizes of the matchings.
Of the old matchings
I should say.
Number of original
maximal matchings
in the input graph of size i,
times n factorial to the i.
OK this is just rewriting.
I'm just this thing, but
I'm summing over all i.
So I have however many matchings
I used to have a size i,
but then I multiply them
by n factorial to the i,
because these are
all independent.
And this thing,
the original number
of matchings in the worst case,
I mean the largest it could be
is when everything
is a biclique.
And then we have n over two
factorial maximal matchings
originally.
And this is smaller than that.
And therefore we can pull
this apart as a number modulo
n factorial.
And each digit is the number of
maximum actions of each size.
And we look at
the last digit, we
get all the number of
maximum matchings of size n
over two also known as the
number of perfect matchings.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So that
second max is maximal?
PROFESSOR: Yes this is maximal.
Other questions?
So again I kind of numbered
[? through ?] trick
by blowing up-- well
by making each of these
get multiplied by a
different huge number
we can pull them apart,
separate them-- In logarithm
these numbers are not huge
so it is actually plausible
you could compute this thing.
And a tree graph you
definitely could do it
by various multiplications
at each level.
All right.
So that's nice, let's do
another one of that flavor.
AUDIENCE: So I was
actually wondering
can you find all those
primes in polynomial time?
PROFESSOR: You could use
the Sieve of Eratosthenes.
AUDIENCE: Is that
like going to be--
PROFESSOR: We can handle pseudo
poly here because as we argued,
the primes are not that big.
So we could just
spend-- we could just
do Sieve of Eratosthenes,
we can afford
to spend a linear time
on the largest prime.
Or quadratic in that even.
You could do the
naive algorithm.
We're not doing real Hogan's
[? mid-number ?] theory here.
I could tell where you
have to be more careful.
All right. .
So here's another question.
What if I just want to count
the number of matchings?
No condition?
This is going to use
almost the reverse trick.
So no maximal constraint
just all matchings,
including the empty matchings.
Count them all.
We'll see why in a moment,
this is quite natural.
So I claim I can do a multicall
reduction to bipartite
number of maximal matchings.
And here are my calls
for every graph g,
I'm going to make
a graph g prime.
Where if I have a
vertex I'm going to add
k extra nodes connected
just to that vertex.
So these are leaves
and so if this vertex
was unmatched over here,
then I have k different ways
to match it over here.
And my intent is to measure this
number of matchings of size n
over two minus k.
That would be the hope.
So if I have m r matchings
of size r over here,
these will get mapped
to Mr times k plus one
to the r, matchings of
size no, not of size.
Matchings over here.
Because for each one I can
either leave it unmatched
or I could add this edge,
or I could add this
edge and that's
true for every unmatched vertex.
Sorry, this is not size r, this
is size n over two minus r.
R is going to be the
number of leftover guys.
Then they kind of
pops out over here.
So I'm going to run
this algorithm-- I'm
going to compute the number of
matchings in Gk for all k up
to like n over two plus one.
So I'm going to do
this and what I end up
computing is number of matchings
in each Gk, which is going
to be the sum over all r.
r is zero to n over two
of Mr the original number
of matchings the size
n over two minus r,
times k plus one to the r.
Now this is a polynomial
in k plus one.
And if I evaluate a polynomial
at its degree plus one
different points I can
reconstruct the coefficients
of the polynomial.
And therefore get all of
these and in particular
get m zero, which is the
number of perfect matchings.
Ta da.
Having too much fun.
Enough matchings.
We have all these versions
of SAT, which are hard.
But in fact there are
even funnier versions
like positive 2SAT.
Positive 2SAT is
really easy to decide,
but it turns out if I add a
sharp it is sharp P complete.
This is sort of like
max 2SAT, but here we
have to satisfy
all the constraints
but you want to count how
many different ways there
are to solve it.
This is the same thing
as vertex cover remember.
Vertex cover's the
same as positive 2SAT.
So also sharp
vertex cover's hard
and therefore also
sharp clique is hard.
So this is actually a
parsimonious reduction
from bipartite matching.
That's why I wanted
to get there.
So for every edge we're going
to make a variable, x of e,
which is true if the edge is
not in the perfect matching.
And so then whenever I have
two incident edges in f,
we're going to have a clause
which is either I don't use e,
or I don't use f.
That's 2SAT, done.
Satisfying?
It's parsimonious.
So satisfying assignments
will be one to one
with bipartite matchings.
So this is why you should care.
And if we instead reduce
from-- did I erase it?
Bipartite maximal
matchings up here,
then I get the
counting the number
of maximally true assignments
that satisfy the 2SAT clause
is also hard.
For what it's worth, a
different way of counting that.
(BREAK IN VIDEO)
Maxwell means you can't set
any more variables true.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Since the edges on
your positive 2SAT reduction
are the variables there are
true when the edge is not
in a matching.
I think it's maximally false.
And not maximally true.
Also maximally true, you just
said everything was true.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Right, right, right, sorry.
I see, you're right.
So it's minimal solutions
for a 2SAT, thank you.
OK in fact, it's known that
three regular bipartite planar
sharp vertex cover.
I won't prove this one.
But in particular you
can make this planar,
although it doesn't look
like we have positive here.
And you can also make it
bipartite, which doesn't
mean a lot in 2SAT land.
But it means-- makes a lot of
sense in vertex cover land.
In my zero remaining
minutes I want
to mention one more concept.
To go back to the
original question
of uniqueness for puzzles.
And you'll see this in the
literature if you look at it.
Lot of people won't
even mention sharp P,
but they'll mention ASP.
ASP is slightly weaker but
for most intents and purposes
essentially identical
notion to sharp P,
from a hardness perspective.
The goal for-- in general,
if I have a problem
a search problem
like we started with.
The ASP version of
that search problem is,
I give you a solution and I want
to know is there another one?
This is a little
different from everything
we've seen because I actually
give you a starting point.
There's some problems
where this helps a lot.
For example, if the solution
is never unique like coloring,
I give you a k
coloring, I can give you
another one I'll just
swap colors one and two.
Or more subtle if I give you
a Hamiltonian cycle in a three
regular graph.
There's always a way to switch
it and make another one.
So ASP is sometimes easy.
But you would basically
use the same reductions.
If you can find a
parsimonious reduction that
also has the property--
so parsimonious reduction
there is a one to one
bijection between solutions
to x and solutions to x prime.
If you could also compute
that bijection, if you can
convert a solution
from one to the other.
Which we could do in every
single proof we've seen
and even the ones
we haven't seen.
You can always compute that
bijection between solutions
of A to solutions of B.
And so what that means is,
if I can solve B, consider
the ASP version of A
where I give you a solution.
If I can convert that solution
into a solution for my B
problem, and then with
the parsimonious reduction
I also get a B instance, then
I can solve the ASP problem
for B. That's a
decision problem.
Is there another solution?
If yes, then A will also
have another solution,
because it's parsimonious
the numbers will be the same.
We need a weaker version of
parsimony we just need the one
and more than one
are kept the same.
If this one was unique then
this one should be unique.
If this one wasn't unique then
this one should be not unique.
If I can solve B
then I can solve A.
Or if I can solve ASP B
then I can solve ASP A.
A lot of these proofs are
done-- so-called ASP reduction
is usually done by a
parsimonious reduction.
And so in particular
this was introduced,
this concept was introduced in
the likes of like Slitherlink,
I think, was one of the early
ASP completeness proofs.
And they were interested
in this because the idea
is if you're designing
a puzzle usually
you design a puzzle
with a solution in mind.
But then you need to make sure
there's no other solution.
So you have exactly
this set up and if you
want a formal definition of ASP
completeness it's in the notes.
But it's not that difficult.
The key point here is if you're
going to prove sharp P or ASP
completeness you might as well
prove the other one as well.
Get twice the results for
basically the same reduction.
All the versions of
3SAT and 1-in-3SAT,
and all those things, those
were all parsimonious.
And all of those are
ASP complete as well.
But once you get
into C-monious you're
no longer preserving one
versus more than one.
So while you preserved--
from a counting perspective
in multicall reductions
where you can divide that off
that's fine.
But from an ASP completeness
perspective you're not fine.
So in fact all the
stuff that we just
did with the permanent
matchings and sharp 2SAT,
their sharp P complete.
They may not be ASP complete.
But you'll notice
the puzzles that we
reduce from like, whatever,
Shakashaka is one of them.
That was from a version of
3SAT, and the other one we had
was from a version
of Hamiltonicity.
This guy.
These are all-- which
was also from 3SAT.
So these are all
ASP complete also.
But if you use the
weirder things like 2SAT
you don't get that.
So usually in one proof you can
get NP hardness, ASP hardness,
and sharp P hardness.
But if you're going to
go from these weirder
problems with C-monious
reductions then
you only get sharp P
hardness, because they're not
even NP-hard.
Cool, all right.
Thank you.